hello believe nation I am super sick
today I I don't know what's wrong the
past week I've been getting vision
problems everything I can't seem to
focus on anything I don't know even now
looking I can't can't seem to focus on
anything I thought I might need glasses
and maybe I still do but today I got so
sick that i had to ahead though I was
gonna pass out I was on a call with
someone paint and said I gotta go I'm
gonna pass it out and I finished a call
at 12 and I went to lie down i woke up
at four had a four hour nap which is
ridiculous I'm feel a little bit better
but groggy and this was a crazy nap I'm
sorry I much it in bed right now making
this because it's supposed to be video
day but check out my check out my bed
here it's like had a massive scary nap
so I'm supposed to be filming today and
I don't know what's going to happen on
the channel for the next week but we'll
see how we go thank you guys for the
support um I'm not even thinking clearly
that's it believe thanks guys I'll see
you soon sign up for the newsletter for
more belief
you